SPEAKER 1: In the CNN Newsroom.
DON LEMON: You know, it
is the largest, largest
school in the world.
It is online.
It is free, and it's expanding.
We'll talk to the founder and
the winner of a $2 million
prize from Google.
OK, so it was two years ago
today that Google announced
Project 10^100.
The goal-- well, it
was to change the world
by helping people.
Google got 150,000 entries.
And today the company
announced five winners.
One is the Khan Academy,
which is a nonprofit that
lets the world learn for
free through its 1,600
online videos.
Now the man behind the Khan
Academy is Salman Khan.
And he joins us now live
from Google headquarters
in Mountain View, California.
Happy day for you?
SALMAN KHAN: It is.
It's pretty exciting.
DON LEMON: Listen--
so tell us, what
do you plan to do
with the Google money?
SALMAN KHAN: Well, as you
mentioned, Khan Academy right
now-- it's actually pushing
close to 2,000 videos.
They've all been produced by me.
We're going to do two
things with the money.
We're going to one, translate
a lot of the content
into some of the world's
major languages--
Spanish, Mandarin, Arabic,
Hindi, Portuguese--
I could keep going on and on.
And we're going to build out the
software part of what we did.
I built out the first version.
But really what this is
going to allow us to do
is become more than just me.
We're going to be
able to hire a team
and turn it into an all-out
virtual school for free.
DON LEMON: Yeah, that's
what people are wondering.
That's what I mean-- that's
the obvious question.
How do you do it?
How do you do school online,
and is it actually viable?
Does it work?
SALMAN KHAN: Well, there's
two parts of school.
One is the learning part, and
one is the credentialing part.
We're tackling the
learning part first.
And I think it does work.
I think when people
go to the site,
they'll see that there's
a lot of testimonials
from a lot of people
who are not just
using this as a supplement.
They're using this
as their substitute
sometimes for what maybe
should go on in the classroom.
We get hundreds of letters
a day from learners
all over the world who use this
as their primary way to learn.
DON LEMON: So listen,
you were-- can
we say that you were
one of the tech guys?
Right, did you do that before?
I know that you worked
in money and business.
I think you were a hedge fund--
you worked in hedge funds,
right?
So how did you just decide to
change and say, you know what?
I'm going to deal
with education.
I'm going to deal with
education and teaching online.
SALMAN KHAN: Well,
there was always
a part of me that wanted to
do something in education.
About five years ago I had a
family member in New Orleans--
I was in Boston at the time--
who needed help with math.
So I started tutoring
her remotely.
And then I started
tutoring her brothers.
And it started
going really well.
But it became hard
to schedule time.
So I said hey, let
me put the-- let
me do my lectures on
YouTube so that we
don't have to schedule our time.
And their feedback,
immediately, was
that they like me better
on YouTube than in person.
Because they got to pause
and repeat, and I guess
there wasn't the stress
of a live interaction
with their cousin.
And I also made it
free for anybody else.
And I started getting
letters from random people
all over the world saying
that these videos allowed them
to pass algebra, or these
videos are the reason
why they didn't
drop out of school
or why they're able
to go back to college.
And I just got excited about it.
I was doing it part time,
really as a hobby while-- as you
mentioned-- working
at a hedge fund.
And then the site kept
growing until last year, where
it got too exciting for me to be
able to focus on my hedge fund
job, so I quit.
And I lived off of
savings for a little bit.
We got a few donations
earlier this year
that allowed me to
take a small salary.
But this Google
award really allows
us to take it to the
next level and turn it
into a real, free,
virtual school.
DON LEMON: What
was your reaction
when you got the Google award?
I'm sure you were ecstatic
because this really helps
things, helps move things along.
SALMAN KHAN: Oh yeah,
it's super exciting.
Obviously, the money is huge.
We'll be able to
build out a team.
internationalize the content so
that more than just
English speakers--
we can start addressing
the other 5 billion people
on the world.
And I think probably
the biggest thing
is that the Google people
are pretty serious thinkers.
And they wouldn't be
throwing around $2 million
for just any effort.
So I think this is a
pretty strong validation
for what we're doing.
DON LEMON: Salman, I
want to ask you this.
You know, the movie Waiting
for Superman opens today,
and it's about education.
And everyone is
trying to figure out
how do we fix the American
educational system.
Do you have any
advice from what you
are doing that we can learn
from for our schools, the brick
and mortar schools?
SALMAN KHAN: You
know, I think people
have been talking
about technology being
a major factor for a while now.
I think the problem is that all
the attempts so far at using
technology have been
to mold the technology
to the traditional
academic model.
What we're trying to do
is really just rethink
how you can learn
now using technology.
And maybe we should mold the
traditional academic model
to how we can use technology.
But I could go on
and on about that.
But I think you're going
to see some major changes
in the next five to ten years.
DON LEMON: Salman Khan
from the Khan Academy.
Congratulations,
and we'll be looking
to see what you are
doing with that money
and how it helps
your effort there.
Thanks again, OK.
SALMAN KHAN: Thank you.